[Music]
russia's invasion of ukraine continues
with putin's forces bombarding the city
of mariappol as russia look to take
their first major ukrainian city will it
fall and with the invasion flagging
what's the russian leaders plan i'm
joined now by dimitri alperovich a
security expert and co-founder of the
silverado policy accelerator think tank
in washington
and mark galiati a spectator contributor
and director of mayak intelligence
dmitry mark thank you for joining us on
spect spectator tv today um dmitry could
you start us off first of all by giving
us a bit of an update on the state of
play when it comes to the war and the
russian invasion ukraine and sort of the
states play for both sides i guess
well by and large the campaign on the
russian side is quite stalled so many of
their access of advance
their attempts to surround kiev have
stalled and in fact due to ukrainian
counter-offensive they've actually been
pushed back out of some of the suburbs
um their attempts to move on odessa
through mikalive or get around nikolai
have also been pushed back by ukrainian
resistance the one area where they're
making progress is mariupo they've been
able to surround the city they've been
able to
bomb it into oblivion of course and uh
increasingly taking territory there if
there's one city that is in danger of
falling in the coming days it is
mariopol and uh once it falls if it
falls they'll be able to take some of
those forces and potentially move them
further north and surround the uh
ukrainian troops or in the donbass
region so things aren't necessarily
great for the ukrainians but the
russians are running into a lot of
problems i'll tell you uh there was a
intercept alleged intercept released by
ukrainian forces this week
which
is a call between a commander on the
ground uh near mikolive area in the
south talking to their superiors in
russia and complaining that 50 of the
troops have frostbite on their feet uh
there have been friendly fire incidents
where their own troops have been bombed
uh through air strikes by russian planes
and potentially artillery as well that
they don't have body armor they don't
have hot food because they don't have a
hot stove so morale is just a complete
disaster and they're saying that the tv
is reporting russian tv that they're
making a lot of progress and taking a
lot of territory but he says we're just
driving through not clearing villages
and then we end up fighting essentially
a 360 degree battle because they're
attacking us from everywhere they've
been the ukrainians of course
and mark it was interesting the u.s
secretary of defense sort of gave a
similar assessment this week he said
also said that the russian advance has
stalled do you agree with that
assessment as well
yeah absolutely i mean i think it's
clear that for a variety of reasons
much to do with the
traditional russian problem of being
more teeth than tail
in other words not really addressing the
logistical backup um the the russians
are in a position where they can launch
local offensives and counter offenses on
a relatively small scale but as dimitri
said except around mario paul they're
not really in a position to actually
mount any major offenses now obviously
they are doing what they can to try and
untangle their supply issues and we
shouldn't get complacent but for the
moment these kind of grand notion of a
sweep across ukraine or at least up to
the nipper river that's clearly not
happening and going further than that
mark do you think there's any chance
that they've been some assessments this
week that ukraine might actually win the
war do you think that goes too far or is
that is that credible
i'm going to be incredibly irritatingly
academic here and say depends what you
mean by when
if you mean are the ukrainians going to
chase every russian out of their country
tail between their legs roll back into
crimea and the donbass regions no i
don't think that's likely to happen at
all if nothing else the point is at the
moment ukrainians have all the advantage
of being on on the defense
as soon as they actually started to move
offensively they would actually
basically lay themselves open some of
the areas in which the russians actually
have particular capabilities but more to
the point there is an element of
exhaustion that will inevitably creep in
i mean even and this is not exhaustion
in the sense of people being tired that
clearly people are tired because we've
seen the ukrainians being willing to
push themselves to to extreme limits
it's just a point about you know at a
certain point
you need to have you know a thorough
replenishment of units you need to
actually have more material and it's not
just simply a question of another bunch
of rockets being sort of passed across
the border and such like so i think what
we are seeing is in many ways ukrainians
are winning by denying the russians any
kind of victory
the prospect of actually the ukrainians
being able to push the russians back
locally is absolutely the case
but this is a war that is going to end
because of some kind of peace deal or
some kind of stalemate it's not going to
see a knockout blow by either side and
you know if i can add the one place i'm
watching very closely is the city of
hersone the one major uh ukrainian city
that the russians have been able to take
over in the early stages of the campaign
and we're seeing a lot of civil
disobedience among the population there
they're coming out on protests there's a
big protest this past weekend they're
blocking traffic uh for russian military
interest guardia national guard units so
they're encountering a lot of local
resistance not yet violent even in the
one place that they've been able to take
over which doesn't bode well for them
being able to control this country even
if they somehow manage to take it over
dmitry i know you mentioned their
pressure on the ukrainian side are we
also going to see pressure on the
russian side i know we've seen
unconfirmed reports of around 10 000
deaths in the russian army is this going
to play significant pressure on putin
essentially when the bodies start coming
home
i don't think so and i would be very
careful about those estimates i think
they're probably a little bit too high
in terms of casualties on the russian
side but you also have to remember that
uh the propaganda machine is operating
full force in russia much of that
information is not filtering down to the
people a lot of the people that are
fighting this war are actually ethnic
minorities there's a lot of chechens
from kaderos units they're fighting the
tough fight in mariopo right now um
there's a lot of people from central
asia that are contractors in the
military so um it's unfortunate to say
this but the majority of the russian
public won't care a whole lot about
those casualties um because just
inherent racism in the society
so i don't think that we're anywhere
close to the point where the casualties
will have an impact on their um uh popul
of the war's popularity back home
and mark we mentioned mario paul back
there and the city has been facing a
huge bombardment in recent days and
weeks do you think this is a sign of a
sort of changing russian strategy which
is just going to be focused on
humanitarian bombings essentially
targeting cities and we're going to see
that more widely now across ukraine do
you think
yes i mean it's an inevitable and
depressing uh side effect of the fact
that their initial
fantastic notions of a rapid blitzkrieg
that'll have the whole country falling
into their lap has failed
now they're having to do it by a sort of
thuggish but
methodical way which is after all i mean
we shouldn't be surprised because this
is what they did in chechnya
this is what they've been doing in syria
that actually
urban combat is very difficult it
requires high levels of skills and
coordination amongst your forces if
you're going to go in to places where
every basement every rooftop could be
housing a sniper or someone who's going
to drop a molotov cocktail on you
it is i'm sad to say a lot easier to
bomb the place into rubble and then to
plant your flag on top
and that is essentially the approach
we're taking i mean from from the
russians point of view after all
to put it very bluntly that they're
looking to conquer parts of ukraine they
don't need the ukrainians
and therefore i think the same way as we
may well see actually increased use of
pressure and humanitarian corridors
being used precisely for
cleansing the area of of as they would
say the population
hesitate to use the word ethnic
cleansing because that has some very
particular implications but certainly
depopulating sort of areas which will
allow the russians greater opportunities
to control them so unfortunately madupo
is probably a harbinger of the future if
the russians are to move on to other
cities
i have to say
we're starting to see that particularly
in that allegedly intercepted call the
officer is saying that their initial
orders were not to destroy the
infrastructure and he's saying we can't
win here without pummeling everything
into the dirt including the civilians
that was literally the quote from this
officer in this alleged intercepted call
so i think the tougher the problem uh
becomes for them the more brutal they
will become in a response
and dmitry are you seeing any signs that
we're getting closer to a negotiated end
to the war or do you think that's still
far too far off to sort of contemplate
you know i'm actually getting very
pessimistic on a negotiated outcome here
we could potentially have a limited
ceasefire because both sides are quite
exhausted and they need to resupply and
take a break but i don't see a lasting
negotiated settlement in part because
the more territory that the russians are
taking like arson if they take mariopol
um and being able to connect on boss to
crimea via this
land bridge and so forth the less likely
i think it becomes that putin will
actually relinquish that territory
and he will demand of course
that territory to be joined to the lnr
and dnr statelets that
he is recognized now in the donbass
region and
that's just not going to be palatable to
zelinski even if he somehow wanted to
make a deal
he just could not sign anything like
that without being run out of town by
his own people so i actually think that
uh the likelihood of a peaceful
settlement here is is very unlikely and
becoming less so by each day
i think i just add in there in some ways
i'm a little bit more in cautiously and
unexpectedly optimistic
only very very slightly because i think
although i agree absolutely with um this
notion that
the russian territorial gains they'll
want to hold on to and zolensky
absolutely would not but on the other
hand what i think is interesting is we
must remember these are two wars being
fought there is a war being fought on
the battlefield in ukraine and then
there is a wider economic war being
waged against russia and i mean we're
already beginning to see that the damage
being done the the empty shells that the
people unable to get medicines and the
real concern amongst the technocrats now
the trouble is obviously the technocrats
who kind of run the economy and such
like they're not putin's in a circle i
mean his basic
um interest in them is just simply their
job is to make sure everything runs and
there is the money for the things that
putin wants to happen
but they're clearly trying to indicate
to the boss that in fact this is not
just simply a situation in which dictat
will be able to get anywhere so i mean
there is a chance that precisely the the
scarring that is being done to the
russian economy and the potential
political implications of that
will actually induce putin to be a
little bit more flexible in terms of
actually a resolution on the battlefield
i only throw that out as a possibility
well i think we're a long way away from
being able to say that we see a deal in
sight but that that is where you know if
there is going to be a peace deal it is
going to be because of the intersection
of these two wars and demetrius i think
the problem though mark is that uh and i
completely agree with you the economic
damage that's been done to russia is
just absolutely massive but i bet you
that putin probably with some reason
thinks that those sanctions and not even
the sanctions but the companies that
pulled out they're not coming back and
and the sanctions uh are not uh going
away in fact the history shows that
sanctions are rarely uh being dropped on
countries once we place them upon um
upon them and uh certainly that's been
the case in russia so uh i have a
feeling that he's thinking he's all in
he's already paid the price and now he
has to get something for it
that's true and i think therefore in a
way the russians would expect some kind
of indications on sanctions to be part
of any peace deal which again makes it a
lot more complex because the ukrainians
can agree what the ukrainians can agree
but they can't speak for the western
sanctions so many moving parts
i mean dimitri you mentioned when you
were last on the show that you thought
the chance of a palace coup against
putin was i think close to zero you said
do you still stand by that or do you
think that the dial is shifted at all
there
i do i i mean you know of course you
know coups happen uh in a way that's
very unpredictable and and we wake up
and find out that a coup has occurred
without much warning in many countries
um you know in russia
i think if there's going to be a coup it
would have to come from the intelligence
services
and they're still quite loyal to him you
know many of the sort of middle uh layer
management may think the boss has gone
mad
but the top level guys are all loyal to
putin you know guys like bortnikov and
narishken have of course been with him
for many years
going back to the kgb days um and um i
don't see him them moving on him anytime
soon um and um you know i just i just
think it's very very unlikely non-zero
but uh close to zero
and mark can we just touch on before we
finish up um how bad do you think the
crackdown is getting in are going on in
russia i know this week that certain
social media sites have been banned in
the country are you getting signs of
sort of increasing authoritarianism
that's building up or do you think we've
sort of reached a plateau with that
oh no um the depressing truth of the
matter is again i think uh you know to
use dmitry's earlier favor phrase about
going all in i think a decision has been
made that if you're going to go a
certain way towards authoritarianism
then you basically will go the rest of
the way i think we are seeing what for a
long time was it was an interesting kind
of hybrid regime which was
authoritarianism with certain aspects of
constitutionalism and certain aspects in
which they did sort of try and address
certain concerns of of the public and
elections were in some ways almost like
national focus groups in that respect
well i think that's that that's all to
the god we are in this respect in some
ways almost heading back to the 1970s
frankly all the progress that has been
lost and that means that not only will
we see increased attempts to try and
insulate russia from the outside world
in terms of news and information
but at the same time we will see a
growing willingness to use you know
violent methods imprisonment and such
like against people who even make the
mildest of criticisms against the regime
and we saw this with when putin's most
recent utterances which are quite
extraordinary i mean his tone was
almost stalinist in what he was saying
about the need for a self-cleansing of
society against the traitors and
parasites and so forth we're not heading
to an age of gulags but we are
definitely heading to authoritarianism
but of course the only point i would
make is that
he might want to bring the regime back
to the 1970s but russians are not the
russians of the 1970s they will have
some sense of what they are losing and
again whether that will bring them out
on the streets or whatever i very much
doubt so long as the security forces
seem loyal and disciplined and willing
to go and crack skulls when need be
but the point is
there will still be a strong anger and
depression i think within society
[Music]
you